good morning believe nation today's
message is you are capable of anything
over to you Ben Carson TV you know the
human brain if you have an average brain
you're capable of almost anything
because of the complexity of our brains
billions and billions of neurons
hundreds of billions of interconnections
it can process more than two million
bits of information in one second it
never forgets anything you've ever seen
anything you've ever heard and you know
with something like that sitting up here
why would you ever utter the words I
can't I mean this comes back again to
the environment that you're in and I've
talked about it over and over and over
again on my channel but it's super
important because if you are filling
your head with information resources
people ideas that are holding you where
you are then you're gonna stay there
right like who in your life is pushing
you to do more who in your life is
saying you know what great job for what
you're doing here that's awesome but you
should be up here you could play this
much bigger game right I believe that
you can cross all these hurdles to get
to being way up here who's doing that in
your life most people don't have that
and so most people just stay where they
are you stay the product of what your
parents are and your friends are there's
a great quote from Steve Jobs it says
something like the world was created by
people who are no smarter than you and
once you realize that you can start to
make changes and it's true you can make
a substantial change in this world on
your life on the lives of many many many
other people but you have to believe
believe that it's possible that you can
do it where most people's vision for
themselves just stays within the bubble
that they're currently operating in
and anything outside is too scary too
much of a change in the comfort zone and
they don't have the strength to push
themselves they get to the edge of their
comfort zone and then they retreat back
in because it's too scary it's too
painful
there's too many limiting beliefs that
you need to cross and without someone to
push you to go through you're not going
to do it that's why the environment is
so important that's why I created the
top 10 series that's why I created the
mentor me Series in the in special
series it for me I want these successful
people to push me to want to do more I
want me to look at what these guys are
doing I feel like what I've done is
great and I'm extremely grateful for it
but I knew I should be playing up here
I'm still just playing here I'm just
playing in the little leagues where I
can be a major league player and I need
to constantly remind myself of that and
you need the constant remind yourself of
that and I try to do that for the people
in my life who are trying to do things
for themselves I believe in people more
than they believe in themselves and I
try to bring them up and if you see
greatness in somebody I believe it's
your responsibility to help them achieve
that greatness to help them push through
their limited beliefs and the issues
that they're going to face in the
hardships and the trials and the excuses
and the BS answers to help them get to
where they should be
so hopefully it could be that person for
the people hopefully could be that for
yourself as well and surround yourself
with the right knowledge with the right
resources with the right people to help
you get from here to here and bridge
that big gap called fear and help you be
a person who can have a major impact on
this world so the question today today
is what are you capable of instead of
focus on a negative and what you feel is
holding you back I want to focus on the
positive today
what are you capable of doing leaving
the comments below
I'm going to join the discussion thank
you guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events pressing ok
nespresso give me go